[Musique]
mon nom est philippe thériault et je
suis illusionniste
c'est un grand honneur d'être parmi vous
ce soir mesdames et messieurs pour vous
partager ma vision mon or on en
reportant de toutes les émotions de la
réalité la magie elle est bien plus
qu'une science quand même si elle repose
sur des méthodes réfléchi sur des
méthodes abouti
elle permet de faire rêver les gens elle
ouvre la boîte ce possible repousse les
limites que l'on nous impose et elles
comblent un besoin profond d'inspiration
je les êtres humains ayant moi même
regarder des vidéos textes dans mon
enfance et encore aujourd'hui je doive
l'admettre être invité à titre de
conférencier à cet événement ce soir est
comme un rêve qui se réalise pour moi ma
passion depuis ma tendre enfance à l'âge
de 7-8 ans et la magie grâce à elle j'ai
pu faire la division des spectacles des
compétitions et même devenir champion
canadien junior de l'année chi une
première dans l'histoire canadienne de
la magie
[Applaudissements]
merci certaines personnes pourraient se
demander comment ai-je pu faire cela
sachant que les magiciens joue sur des
impressions qui le manipule apparemment
seulement que l'esprit humain
eh bien j'aimerais vous dire d'emblée
que la magie elle existe elle existe au
même titre que la musique par exemple
elle est en or et même s'il semble rien
y avoir de vraies au départ et fait
pourtant être quelque chose en nous
comme un peu une flamme s'allume
elle suscite des réactions et
d'émerveillement cela pourrait paraître
paradoxal quand même de me faire venir
pour vous parler d'un tel sujet car ma
profession divisionnistes consiste à
créer des illusions d impression soit
apparemment rien du tout certaines
personnes pensent même que la magie
n'existe pas un fil ces personnes
pensent qu'elle ne peut concrètement se
produire et qu'elle relève davantage de
la science que de l'idée qu'on s'en fait
dans notre imaginaire collectif
eh bien ça m'a souvent fait mal en faire
un tel constat est parfois quand les
gens me demandent quoi qu'il arrive
rarement
qu'est ce que je ferais un an plus tard
qui sera plus tard philippe on me répond
je vais être magicien je vais continuer
à faire de la magie et que ça suscite
des reer ou de l'incompréhension salle à
vivre en main je dois avouer que la
plupart du temps je suis un
je suis entouré accompagné de gens qui
croient en ce que je fais et qui sont
capables d'apprécier à sa juste valeur
le travail dédié à produire de nouveaux
actes par contre je me suis rendu compte
que les gens qui ne croient pas en ma
passion croit pas vraiment la magie sont
souvent ces mêmes personnes qui ne
croient pas en leurs rêves leurs cd qui
dépense est réalisable parce que c'est
davantage synonyme de magie que de
réelles possibilités de carrière donc
imaginez un instant quand quelqu'un a
redit qu'il va être magicien aucun sens
alors je pense que c'est une erreur
grave erreur de croire cela puisque vous
qui est devant moi vous voulez avoir une
place dans le monde de demain je parle
aussi étudiants qui sont ici par exemple
vous voulez en place dans le monde de
demain vous voulez vous trouver un rôle
important dans la société et je pense
que pour aboutir à quelque chose
m'importe l'âge on a aussi pour aboutir
à quelque chose il faut nécessairement
partir de quelque chose et ce quelque
chose là ni nulle autre que la passion
on entendu précédemment dans les autres
conférences mais ce raisonnement prépare
est très simpliste à première vue mais
il fait partie des vérités fondamentales
sur lesquelles je me bats pour réussir
dans la vie comme on agit j'ai réalisé
que les gens qui réussissent savent
créer de la valeur la valeur là aussi le
plus inattendu en pensant leurs
activités à partir de principes
fondamentaux et non pas de quelques
formules la passion quant à elle le
pousse à trouver des idées à passer à
l'acte et à s'inscrire dans le monde
tout en laissant au passage on espère
une trace tel est mon but avec la magie
je pense aussi que peu importe la
mission qu'il ya les actes qui ont la
plus grande valeur aux humains sont
d'abord ceux qui viennent du coeur avant
tout d'où l'importance d'avoir une
passion et c'est encore mieux cette
passion l'a peut être attaché un désir
ardent d'accomplir quelque chose pour ce
qui est de la magie je pense que
l'essence son essence même relève dans
l'expérience qu'ont fait d'elle un peu
la magie ni comme magie dans le moment
l'instant où on en est témoin et qu'on y
croit on fait le se veut le moment
présent et nous amène à prendre
conscience des merveilles de la vie qui
nous entoure
une très belle façon quand même de
réaliser c'est merveilleux je pense que
si on la considère comme une science ou
simple science avait ensuite en fait une
science qu'on peut expliquer plus tôt
par un enchaînement de proposition et
conséquences sur lequel on peut revenir
et modifié ce que vous savez
jeudi que des fois y'a des spectateurs
une croix qui ne croient pas en la magie
mais le souci des magiciens qui ne font
rien pour vraiment faire en sorte que
l'offre puisse s'épanouir en utilisant
par exemple des trucages de caméras même
si le public s'en rend pas toujours
compte selon moi c'est pas une façon
d'élever la magie en tant que tel donc à
ce moment l'heure si on la considère
comme science on s'éloigne de son essai
en semaine et elle n'existe plus prenons
l'exemple cinéma si on regarde un film
et on s'attarde aux techniques de
production à la manière dont les effets
cinématographiques sont orchestrées
ensemble et bien la magie du film
disparation vue puisque le visionnement
d'un film fait naître des sensations
similaires à une prestation
d'illusionnisme cependant même si les
émotions paraissent éphémère qui m'a
vraiment semble être spontanée dans le
domaine de la prestidigitation qui est
un très long bois en passant pour dire
magie et bien je pense que l'émotion
transmise au public par le magicien peut
demeurer gravé dans les esprits
longtemps au même titre que l'histoire
d'un film qui nous aurait marqué
plusieurs mois plusieurs années après
l'avoir vu je dirais aussi que chaque
spectateur interprètent différemment le
tour qui lui est présenté dépendamment
de ce qu'il a vu à certains moments
précis ou encore de son expérience
personnelle dans la vie manqué et il
tire parfois même je dirais très souvent
sa propre conclusion du numéro par
exemple m'arrive fréquemment en
incorporer de faux erreurs dans mes
numéros de cette façon-là j'amène mon
auditoire à croire qu'il n'y a aucune
issue possible pour moi est que la fin
du tour est vouée à l'échec
bien évidemment c'est pourquoi c'est
monté toute pièce et là c'est là qu'il a
en partie de rôles rentrent en ligne de
compte c'est que les gens pensent que je
me suis manquer les bombardements et
vendus à de la machinerie échapper ces
choses ici tromper et puis là il se met
à rire on voit le sourire dans le visage
et là c'est plutôt moi qui ce qu'il y de
l'intérieur puisque je cite précisément
qu'à ce moment là lorsque va arriver le
climax la fin de l'acte le prestige si
on veut du tour de magie
et bien c'est là que la sensation de
magie va être surélevée et qu'elle va
devenir davantage impossible et s'il y
avait eu aucun obstacle entre ce que ce
que j'avais fait que j'étais arrivé à la
fin du numéro comme un peu comme les
procédures conçues dans une démarche
scientifique on était arrivé à la fin
que ça se produit encore le jeu reprend
l'analogie des films puisque c'est la
meilleure je pense c'est un personnage
principal tendance à kate et qu' aucun
en bouche devant lui aucun obstacle
aucune péripétie
ça sert à quoi de regarder films c'est
ennuyant franchement on s'est mis deux
pôles au regard du tout inquiet alors je
pense que c'est la même chose en magie
si les machines font un tour et que ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien
une fois bien sûr c'est cool quand ça
fonctionne bien mais je pense que ça
peut rajouter expliquant que ça peut
rendre le numéro présenté encore plus
intéressant dans le même ordre d'idées
je pense aussi que le l'interprétation
d'un tour passe par la personnalité
d'une machine ou de la machine qui
produit les faits en question en fait eu
presque 100 ans de ça même plus je
dirais le père de la magie moderne jean
eugène robert houdin qui est influencé
des générations de mes chiens par le
passé des général génération entend
devenir aussi qui m'a influencé beaucoup
ozzie un magicien est un acteur jouant
habilement le rôle de magicien certaines
personnes voient même le penser machin
sont acteurs qui font semblant d'être
magicien puis ça finit bien avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour lui je me permets
de le contredire
aujourd'hui on encore de l'événement en
fait je pense que l'authenticité
l'authenticité total autant que possible
la personnalité peut se refléter dans
les visions et lui conférer une
dimension davantage artistique et
mystifiante où le public va s'attacher
plus facilement le faire au magicien ce
qui est présente et vous accorder plus
d'importance à son oeuvre
en derniers piliers sur lesquels on
pourrait se pencher parce que je pensais
plus que pertinent savoir comment la
faire exister cette magie là et je vous
ai parmi les centaines de milliers
d'heures de travail qui qui en découlent
avec les frustrations les passions aussi
qu'ils mangent
avais je vous dire simplement que pour
faire exister la nage il faut y croire
et se savent s'applique dans n'importe
quel domaine près pendant ce que vous
faire il faut croire en ce qu'on fait
c'est celui ou celle qui produit un
effet qui doit croire en ce qu'il fait
il ya donc une vérité fondamentale ici
encore c'est à dire qu'il doit avoir une
conviction dans l'action c'est tout
simplement l'importance de croire en ce
que l'on fait quand j'ai commencé à
pratiquer mon art j'avais peur comment
dire g
je n'étais pas capable de bien mesurer
l'impact que pouvait avoir magie sur mon
public je n'ai pas capable de bien
mesurer les conséquences qui ça devait
tout ça pouvait avoir
lemagit dans leur vie j'ai perdu de vue
un peu la sensation que j'avais vécu la
première fois où j'avais été exposés à
cette heure-là
en fait ça me distancier de mon public
puisque j'avais que la passion manipuler
des objets d'apprendre de nouvelles
techniques non chez mes connaissances
départ faire et de les appliquer pour
ébahir les gens ce qu'ils étaient
corrects mais je pense que c'était la
meilleure façon de faire étant donné que
je suis je suis l excellence et que je
suis encore l'excellence à part une
vision mécanique de monheurt trouve
scientifiquement un peu distancé des
gens et l'importance à la magie n'était
plus la même
l'importance qu'il a accordé à ce que je
faisais puisque les gens le voient pas
ce qui est présenté sur scène uniquement
ce qu'on voit ce que mashimo fin comme
mouvement que certains comme numéro
comment qui se comporte sur scène y
aussi ce qui ne se voit pas ce qui se
ressent et selon moi c'est dans ce lot
qui réside la vraie magie celle qui
touche les gens donc je pense qu'on est
rattachée à un désir en temps une raison
de performer en effet je peux réellement
faire une différence tout en élevant mon
art et en faisant progresser laisse
maintenant vous montrer une petite
démonstration
qu'est ce qui pourrait ressembler à un
classique en magie en fait ça n'étonne
c'est le fameux tour du papier déchiré
et reconstituer
c'est un taux très ordinaire puisque
justement le papier déchiré et
reconstituer
mais je pense que lorsqu'on veut élever
la magie on peut par exemple en faire
plus avec un numéro comme celui là et le
transformer pour par exemple
métaphoriser l'amour puisque vous savez
il ya juste la magie dans nos vies qui
est magique
il y aussi l'amour qui apportent des
instants les moments très magique et
donc je pense que avec la région peuvent
représenter ce que le ce que l'amour
peut faire à notre coeur
tout en rendant au passage encore plus
fort
[Applaudissements]
pour conclure je vous dirais que peu
importe que l'esprit capable de réaliser
imaginez on fait plutôt de penser de
réaliser nous sommes en mesure de le
produire et la magie là pour le prouver
lorsque nous commençons à douter à nous
questionner sur la méthode employée pour
réaliser en effet la magie n'existe
simplement pu la même chose se produit
si vous me permettez l'analogie encore
une dernière fois avec nos rêves
si nous commençons à en douter nous
sommes paralysés nous avons peur d'aller
de l'avant nous sommes habités par la
peur ça ne fonctionne plus au 20ème
siècle offre à mu prolifique magicien
harry houdini audi que la magie était la
seule science que les scientifiques ne
comprenais pas je pense que s'il vient
ici c'est parce que la magie est en or
elle est en or pourtant de toutes les
émotions de la réalité elle peut avoir
un effet sur la réalité par la mesure où
nous y croyons merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]